why don't I think I can do this don't
have like you don't have to offer
hey you plan events before you raise
money yes that's on a bigger scale but
but you weigh more now
I like that metaphor but I appreciate
science this season ISA is lucky filling
herself my character has definitely
leveled up over the last three seasons
did you see where she started did you
see that job yeah I think that she is
way more confident than she was when we
first saw her but definitely still has a
lot of insecurities about where her life
is headed in general she's leveling up
inspiration I think Molly is low-key
buggin Molly needs to grow up and a lot
of different ways both personally and
professionally the really hard part
about growth is knowing that you have to
but not knowing how to this season
Lawrence is low-key going through a job
I think there's a lot of growth for
Lawrence there's some moments in here
where we get to see him like really have
to take a step up or he can revert it's
not the relationship is work it's now
worked and it's some other [ __ ] you
still doing way better than you were
last year you were above season four
Kelly is Loki handling it she is who she
says she is and she's consistent in that
way I couldn't even do this without him
well yeah you can't get yourself
pregnant yes okay google it I think
Tiffany has going for girls in just her
ability to be vulnerable
she's very about keeping up appearances
and I think we're not sure if that's
about being private or if that's about
being perfect
this season you can expect growing pains
you can expect self-care and growth does
that girl will say work is draining me
well it takes time
you know he's got all these little
accountable now you got to burn your
yoga mat
[Music]
you